[Musique]
bon
il s'appelle karim braire il a grandi
dans un quartier sensible d'orléans une
genèse de petits délinquants l'année de
sa majorité il écope de 6 mois de prison
avec sursis pour tentative de vol à
partir de là
sa vie va prendre une direction
inattendue
donc là on à biarritz et en chaussons
long plissé le scot de la côte des
basques maniacs 18 ans plus tard c'est à
700 km au sud d'orléans que nous
retrouvons carré bonjour eric ça va ça
va ouais
très bien je viens pour la fosse ouais
c'est un peu d'apnée
[Musique]
maintenant c'est en moi lolo l'eau la
mer l'océan
cette nature les kids aquatique c'est
devenu ma vie mon quotidien et je
pourrais pas m'en passer je pourrais
plus m'en passer
[Musique]
karim braire a grandi dans la cité des
blossières à orléans des parents
immigrés marocains et trois frères et
soeurs quand on est dans la cité on n'a
pas le sentiment d'être différent c'est
quand on est en dehors de la cité qu'on
a le sentiment d'être différent voire
anormal donc non non j'ai des supers
souvenirs ici avec mes potes d'enfance
avec
toutes les familles qui habitaient là
puisqu'on était assez soudé solidaire et
c'est un cocon porno mais le père de
karim se tue dans un accident de voiture
l'année de ses 15 ans et la famille va
connaître la pauvreté
j'ai pris une claque dans le sens où
il est parti au moment où j'aurais eu le
plus besoin d'un père fois c'est à dire
à 15 ans où tu commences à être un peu
un homme et et que tu as envie d'un de
trac rocha un modèle l'adolescent
basculent dans la délinquance vols et
trafic de drogue
ils demandent une dérogation pour le
lycée voltaire à l'autre bout de la
ville il y avait des échanges entre
entre les quartiers d'orléans a
notamment produit stupéfiant donc je
rendais service en ramenant quelque
quantité ici pour pouvoir approvisionner
à la source dans chaque ville il y à un
moment où tout peut basculer pour karim
braire tout s'est joué exactement ici à
la médiathèque d'orléans où sa mère
l'avait obligé à accompagner sa soeur
venus emprunter un livre la voie de la
voile la pêche gros compte c'est la
revue de surf qu'il ouvre ne sachant pas
encore qu'une image va changer son
destin du moment vous vu cette photo
dans ce magazine avec ce gars dans ce
tube cristallin
j'étais sûr d'être sur seraient et puis
à part sur la scène obsession et j'ai
tout mis en oeuvre pour le problème
c'est qu'il ne sait pas nager
le destin l'a encore va mettre sur son
chemin christine du mans ce qui est à
l'époque responsable de la formation de
maîtres nageurs sauveteurs à orléans
je me rappelle que quand j'étais venu me
renseigner ses vers toi qu'on m'avait
orienté et et c'est à toi que j'ai eu à
faire et et ce à partir de toits que
tout a commencé pour moi pour présenter
volonté de proposer au plus grand nombre
après
tu avais passé des tests il y avait un
test à passer ce fameux test où j'étais
pas plus compétent que ça puisque
j'étais manager et il y avait il y avait
d'ailleurs c'était c'était là sur cette
longueur là avec les mains tous les
nageurs confirmés qui venait des clubs
pour s'inscrire et au mois j'étais un
peu plus un peu plus ridicule que grâce
à ce soutien
le jeune homme fait partie des 50% deux
élus qui obtiennent leur bnssa
le brevet national de sauvetage
aquatique qui s'inhale a représenté pour
moi cette main tendue est la porte
ouverte à un autre horizon pour moi quoi
au delà du quartier en obtenant ce
diplôme ça me permettait de me
rapprocher du bord de mer et de changer
de position
le bord de mer se sera biarritz bien sûr
le paradis des surfeurs
[Musique]
mais elle était terminée c'est plutôt
l'enfer pour le jaune or les années qui
se retrouve sans le sou sur le parking
de la plage des cavaliers
j'avais une super 5 rouges et que
j'avais aménagé avec un bout d'éponger
en retirant le siège à l'arrière qui me
servait de deux lits et et à l'intérieur
près de moi proche de moi je chérissais
ma planche de surf ma première planche
de surf avec laquelle j'ai commencé à
apprendre à surfer voilà on arrive sur
la plage des cavaliers à deux pas de là
où ma voiture était garée et jusqu'à ce
que les conditions météo se dégradent en
hiver c'était le rêve de pouvoir se
lever le matin à deux pas de la plage
quoi est d'arriver le matin sierre avec
sa planche sous le bras
avant de tenir debout sur cette planche
karim va passer de longues semaines dans
l'eau ignorés et rejetée par les
surfeurs locaux dérangés par cette arabe
de banlieue qui ne possède aucun des
codes en vigueur sur la côte basque
la première vague l'a attendu déjà avec
impatience et j'attendais cette
sensation pendant tout l'hiver tous les
verts j'ai galéré essayer d'en prendre
mais j'ai fini par en prendre humer et
c'était pas la vague espérer puisque
c'est vrai que vu de l'extérieur elle
pouvait paraître ridicule puisque j'ai
fait un un pauvre tout droit jusqu'au
bord dans une mousse mais cette
sensation à m'a jamais quitté et je
savais que c'était vraiment ça que je
voulais ressentir tous les jours depuis
sept années 2000 la vie de karim a
changé il est désormais sponsorisé par
des marques de matériel et s'est
installée définitivement à biars est le
gamin des blossières est devenu surfeur
professionnel
donc ça c'est ma planche de taurine de
sur ce tract est la plus importante
elle fait quinze kilos c'est la planche
qui me permet de surfer des vagues au
dessus de 15 mètres et jusqu'à jusqu'à
30 mètres voire plus en fonction de deux
des vagues que je rencontrerai dans ma
carrière
[Musique]
désormais karim surf aux quatre coins du
monde
hawaï à tahiti et très souvent à
quelques kilomètres de chez lui
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de grosses
vagues à l'horizon juste le plaisir
d'attendre et de glisser sur l'eau
[Musique]
ouais je suis devenu un homme de la mer
non mais je ne pourrai plus jamais me
passer de la mer c'est quelque chose de
naturel c'est quelque chose de très
profond en moi et et je le répète
orléans ça pouvait paraître bizarre mais
mais non en fait c'est vraiment mon truc
et ça me correspond tout à fait et je
suis totalement épanouie
un bonheur qui aurait pu être sans
histoire mais le surf français est un
petit milieu qui voit d'un très mauvais
oeil le succès médiatique de l'ancien
quai d'orléans après la sortie de son
livre aux armes à sunset les réseaux
sociaux se déchaîne karim braire est
accusé d'avoir tout inventé
ou presque stevan cobaye est un blogueur
reconnu dans le milieu du surf il a mené
sa propre enquête
ce que j'ai cherché à démontrer c'est
pas dire karim est un ange karim n'a
rien fait car il n'est pas un mythomane
car il met machin s'agit c'est pas ça
que je cherchais à dire c'est juste à
dire en fait ce mec là là juste une
histoire racontée vient la cité
d'orléans que ce mec-là et prétend à
rien si ce n'est tombée est tombé
amoureux du surf réaliser son rêve venir
et devenir un surfeur point barre elle
est jusqu'à et que effectivement il
s'intéresse au sort bureau et que ça
soit 5,10 m 20 m on s'en fout c'est
parti du coup de pied que j'ai pu mettre
dans la formule r quand je suis arrivé
en faisant une entrée fracassante dans
le milieu du surf au sens propre comme
au figuré puisque j'ai eu à en venir aux
mains régulièrement quand je suis arrivé
dans la région puisque
ils m'ont jamais accepter et à travers
le localisme c'est normaux c'est leurs
mots clés pourquoi dire raciste
il appelle ça être un local ils n'ont
pas le monopole du désamour
moi aussi je ne les aime pas
et ce gros banc de sable à il ferait une
super vague
loin des polémiques karim apprécient la
tranquillité des bords de loire au
blossières à deux pas de chez lui il
retrouve un personnage qui a marqué sa
jeunesse
ça va mais ça va bientôt ni la mouche
une célébrité locale a été champion du
monde de culturisme
c'est vers tonique s'est naturellement
tourné karim lorsqu'il a compris qu'il
lui faudrait sérieusement développer sa
masse musculaire pour devenir surfer
donc là j'ai ma petite paire d'haltères
pourquoi j'ai encore pas mal être apaisé
un t1 des trapèzes 1 me et tony fait du
tony on dirait que c'est quelqu'un de
gentil dans la vie mais à l'entraînement
c'est pas quelqu'un de gentil mais c'est
quelqu'un de très exigeant
c'est quelqu'un de très droit à l'époque
le gamin des blossières est resté
longtemps sans voix devant l'empilement
des trophées 10 on se retrouve sur le
fait d'avoir été au bout de notre rêve
est d'avoir fait quelque chose d'un peu
utopiste et décalé par rapport à là où
on vit mais mais le parcours de tony les
plus complets que le mien puisque lui il
a acquis des titres
[Musique]
dans la vie de karim il y avait bien des
occasions de sortir de la cité lorsqu'il
était enfant
la famille ne rateraient pour rien au
monde les fêtes de jeanne d'arc
[Musique]
à part jean marie le pen qui est
persuadé d'être un proche de jeanne
d'arc
on sait tous nous entre corlay n'est que
jeanne d'arc ne lui appartient pas et
nous appartient à nous les orléanais et
que jeanne d'arc c'est beaucoup plus que
une récupération politique jeanne d'arc
c'est une histoire une culture et une
femme extraordinaire en tout cas dans
son parcours et comme j'aime à le
répéter je m'identifie souvent elle-même
dans le surf
voilà on a pu la traiter de folle et on
a pu ne pas l'accepter en tant que femme
dans les rangs de l'armée et moi c'est
pareil on n'a jamais accepté dans le
milieu du surf et dans les rangs de
l'armée du sort
[Musique]
comme toutes les histoires celle ci à sa
morale c'est le message de karim aux
enfants des cités ceux qui grandissent
avec le sentiment d'être impuissant
devant leur avenir
[Musique]
j'ai juste envie de leur dire qu' il n'y
a pas d' excuses pour s'en sortir il n'y
a pas d' excuses pour aller au bout de
ses rêves et que eux aussi ont le droit
de rêver et vous aussi
les jeunes de cités vous avez droit de
rêver et et croyez moi vous avez de l'or
dans les mains vous avez de l'ordre dans
la tête et et malgré qu on vous
encourage pas assez souvent et malgré
qu'on vous tente pas la main sachez que
vous pouvez faire de belles choses et de
grandes choses moi je suis devenu
surfeurs et les gens peuvent devenir
tout autre chose qui n'a aucun rapport
avec la cité
à partir de son histoire karim braire a
construit et notoriété
en attendant que son livre soit portée
sur grand écran le gamin des blossières
parcourt le monde à la recherche des
vagues de légende celle qui lui procure
l'adrénaline de sa jeunesse
[Musique]